one of the reasons why it's good to have
coyotes around it's good to have ours
all those think hawks all those things
keep the rat population down so people
run around killing hawks and owls and
and you know that was also a problem
with people that leave out poison cuz
you leave out poison for the rats and
the rats eat the poison then the Owls
eat the rats and they get poison they
die
oh yeah that's an issue that's no good
we have coyotes too they come out in
broad daylight yeah you got to be
careful those little [ __ ] or any kids
oh yes and around its small my little
dogs doing a little shitty dogs you
don't need to yep can't yeah oh yeah
yeah they'll they'll bite your [ __ ]
kids yeah I mean if no one's around you
know if you leave a kid in the yard
three-year-old kid I'm just gonna mommy
us take a [ __ ] right back come back out
to a half-eaten kid I take my kid with
me to take a [ __ ] I put him on my lap
when I [ __ ] you have to of course I'm
not gonna let my kid be alone you know
wait three roads get into everything
especially with [ __ ] animals
that's dark mm-hmm that's a weird thing
like those coyotes are really their
predators that are wandering we know we
had a big issue with them because we
have chickens and they started killing
some of our chickens but then we
realized we were targeted like our yard
is targeted by these little tiny wolves
it's very strange sort of wild creatures
that are sneaky Oh smart and they can
jump over walls - mm-hmm forget it man
you jump over walls like nothing like
six-foot fence they bounced to the top
of the fence then bounced over it like
it's not even there [ __ ] they're elegant
I know the way they move it's really
kind of beautiful to watch they look
like just dogs like I'll see them in the
neighborhood hmm oh [ __ ] that's a coyote
do like at first really excited
someone's dog and then you just see them
kind of skulking they just you know do
you I like looking at him but then I
know what they're capable of and you're
like get the [ __ ] out of here dog for
sure lot of dogs
I had a friend she had her doggy and ran
in front of her shed little Maltese
lived out in Westlake Village in the
broad daylight she was just standing in
the backyard with the little Maltese and
a coyote just came and snatched it up
right in front of her and just
just went away with it you're like
there's my there goes my dog broad
daylight wow we got two little shits I
don't let them run around in the charge
oh yeah of course she was devastated she
was traumatized love that dog you know
it's you know what the Maltese is
essentially a lab dog you're not
training that thing to do much else I've
been sleep with you and love yeah so
it's a it's a member of the family and
yeah it's like [ __ ] coyote snatches
it up crazy it's hard out there for a
coyote though they got a fat dog slippin
yeah stupid [ __ ] a dog getting fed by
these people that's right but they won't
[ __ ] with Marshall right like he's too
big yeah he's too big maybe two of them
could try to take him down
they might yeah I mean if they felt like
he wasn't gonna do anything about it
they felt like he was submissive or they
felt like they could just get a hold of
them you know who knows they've
definitely killed dogs as big as him
before